we had sexy scenes I feel connected with
Chase emotional exits oh my god therapy
I really truly think I am a better
person with you this is your The
Bachelor greatest seasons ever episode
full recap grab your glasses it's time
for roses and rose hey hi everybody it's
me Lauren Zima yes I think this is
episode 4 is yeah we did Sean and
Catherine we did Kaitlyn we did Ben we
didn't know Jo Jo Fletcher seemed than
everybody yeah everybody coming to you
with a blog from the floor I love to
floor sit as I call it and car sit I
find it comforting do you do this let me
know in the comments below
I wanted to bring up something I think
some of you might have missed I only
posted about it on Instagram some of you
have been asking why we didn't do a
roses in Rosie episode for Sean Lowe and
Kathleen Geordi cheese episode of The
Bachelor goat the premiere episode we
didn't do it because I wanted to give
the spotlight instead to the movement
that's happening around the country to
talking about diversity that needed to
happen in The Bachelor franchise this
was before the announcement of Matt
James as the bachelor which was a
crucial step forward so instead of doing
roses in rows a that week I did an
interview with Rachel Lindsay and we put
that up on YouTube instead so that was
why there was no episode and I love Sean
and Catherine so much their episode of
The Bachelor goat was great I loved
watching and reliving it because I had
actually not watched that whole season
all the way through so some real
characters there okay so anyway that's
happening I'm gonna go back to the floor
so comfortable I love you so much bye
how is everybody I have a little story
to share just something to acknowledge
you talked about the elephant in the
room just get it off the table this
shirt has stains
yes so I thought to myself you know it's
been so long since they purchased or
wore a new item of chic clothing here in
the quarantine I've had some fabulous
sweat suit moments but you know some
ones were the unkennel life so I bought
this it just feels like 22 honey to me
doesn't it you know like even when
you're trying you're being held back a
little bit you know and that's the vibe
of this year I didn't notice it until I
was dressed and ready to go so we're
just gonna keep rocking it we're gonna
draw the eye away with these sparkly
buttons draw the eye up here keep the
focus here and because we were feeling
extra chic today we have one of my
favorite a chardonnays rum Bauer if you
don't drink it you're missing out and
you know what I'm missing a stem yes I
really was being risky with those
stemmed glasses you guys so I've gone
back to stemless so we are giving a big
pour today for our girl Jojo did you
watch this season of The Bachelorette
I loved this season everybody for many
reasons
I remember Jojo being a great lead she
had some very unforgettable guys it was
the first season we did roses and
oh my gosh we gotta pull up a little bit
of that footage and give it a look-see
it's time for roses and Rosie Wow cheers
to that cheers to the beginning of roses
and rose day back in the 2016 but JC and
I have been on the journey together the
whole time because snazzy JC is looking
today I mean I've come here with stains
he's come here with a slicked-back
ponytail and a haircut just like this
stained chic shirt is representing 2020
he's anyone else feeling like this show
kind of is it's like we're looking back
in order to move forward what I love to
see is the growth on the shows is the
circle and back with people let's escape
for a moment with Jo Jo Fletcher season
of The Bachelorette and we're really
starting off with an escape because
right off the bat we catch up with the
wonderful Welles Adams and his fiancee
actress Sarah Hyland and what was that
room this white glowing space I was just
like Welles and Sarah
so wherever they were zooming from it
looks tranquil and peaceful and full of
love and light and that's great and they
were great they're always a delight they
have so much fun together I love to see
it what's the saying all's fair in love
and war you know especially because
we're gonna get into Welles his journey
to find that love and it had some
awkward and hilarious moments and I
think Welles himself is totally fine
with saying that but yes Jo Jo season
had some guys who are very much still in
the bachelor world today some familiar
faces and don't drink for every pun hon
right off the bat we got grantees a
firefighter here to start a fire I hope
that Jojo is the one that lights my fire
Jordan he's a football player here to be
your draft pick I'm hoping I'm gonna be
JoJo's number one draft and Devon bass
he is the owner of some
erectile-dysfunction clinics and his job
is hard
it's a hard business those went from
like G to n c---seventeen real quick so
okay great we love a pun we love a pun I
got my mojo for Jim Jim um oh this is so
good buttery some great guys you know
just hot guys don't drink for every time
Jojo talked about how hot her guts were
so much hotness right now and you know
what add in there every time they talked
about how beautiful she is she's
gorgeous
he's the hottest Bachelorette there's
ever been like him by far you see her
and you're like this would set the scene
for what I had forgotten was a pretty
sexual season we're gonna go over some
of the highlights dates and one of them
being oh I did not forget about this
Jojo and chase doing tantric yoga and
constantly say this is the first time
I've mounted a guy on my first date it's
nothing sexy you're gone I haven't been
working out oh and reveal I'm not
wearing shoes okay
there's like an attraction there for
sure they were in this like warm yoga
room getting really sexy it was very
cinematic and speaking of hot now it's
time for the firefighter day Oh first I
know I do seem to have more mobility in
my neck you guys and thank you so much
for your concern I went to an
acupuncturist slash chiropractor who
said that I am sleeping on my stomach
because I'm stifling trauma and then put
magnets on the back of my ears because
he said that my magnetic energy was off
he told me that I was in fact leaning
that I was not structurally sound and he
asked me Lauren would you live in a
house that was leaning in I said no so
here we are magnets serrano firefighter
date and the guys had to put on all the
gear and like use the hoses and really
fight fires and speaking of liquids
don't drink every time someone said
Wells was going to faint
Will's looks like he's meant to pass out
Wells is about to pass out he's very
pale and he's kind of falling he's
looking a little lightheaded
grant about to faint yes well Adams was
not doing well that day and you guys I
was actually there that was the day I
went and did interview son a little
behind the scenes they gave Wells to me
to interview him it was the first time I
met him such a great guy I always
thought she was the prettiest girl on
the last season but like a little weird
in the interview and I was surprised
because they told me all this guy's a
radio DJ so it'll be a great interview
he was like still feeling quite faint I
was doing the interview and then they
said you know what we gotta stop this
he's gonna pass am I having a hard time
shaking me you seem a little tired I'm a
lot tired so at least now we know doing
well
[Music]
Besame Mucho ciao love Jojo but Wells
wasn't doing all that well because he
was still the guy who hadn't kissed the
girl okay I'll be I'll be frank with you
guys I'm the one guy I think I think
here that hasn't kissed her as well
Adams was the only man in the mansion
who had not kissed
Jojo yet and this might have been a
first for the franchise
they gave Wells a one-on-one date like
literally contrived to get him to kiss
Jojo all I'm waiting for is for Wells to
make the move
but anyway
[Music]
I just love Jojo she's always been so
nice every time I've ever met her and
she was so supportive
when have you ever kissed someone and
they cheered you on for making it happen
you know so sweet we raise a glass to
support to positivity to lift in each
other
[Music]
but you know on the CliffsNotes show
we're doing our cat jobs and so we're
gonna go back to Wells and Sarah on the
zoo it's another one of those update
happy moment you know what it was just
so wonderful that Sarah confirmed for
the world Wells is a great kisser is he
a good kisser
he's the best Wells was doing well
lifting each other up
[Music]
and you guys here's the thing you know
we look at Wells and we see the growth
and that's what I've been liking about
this highlights CliffsNotes ketchup show
The Bachelor the greatest seasons ever
you know at some moments it's also a
little strange to look back through the
lens of today one of the unforgettable
characters on Jojo season of The
Bachelorette was as he was called bad
Chad Johnson - a beautiful girl a
beautiful life you guys i'ma make her my
wife he went on paradise it's just like
a lots happened he's done a lot of
things since then and we didn't have a
catch up with him and I just don't
really want to talk about it I don't I
don't want to get into the chat of it
all and I can't look at it with like the
same playfulness as I did back then so
we're just gonna drink for the
fast-forwarding sayonara Chad but as I
do with anybody
I hope Chad's okay I wish him the best
truly lift each other
but you know this is another great
lesson sometimes we get growth and
changed and sometimes we just look for a
silver lining and Aven bass is here with
it yes Evan and shad infamously but it
heads and almost came to blows but Evans
said look without Chad he might not have
stood out on the show as much and so he
wouldn't have gone to paradise Chad made
me a better person and I was able to
find Carly because of that are Carly and
the kids there he met Carly and they
have two beautiful babies and sing well
me Nate was so cute I love it so much
Silver's I'm so I'm sweating in this
shirt that I bought I'm sweating it's
not really breathing it's stained it's
got the strange crease the tucks getting
weird
don't drink for everything wrong with my
shirt draw the eye up look at the
buttons silver lining literally it's a
silver line so with Chad we had the
badness but on Jojo season we also had
the sadness with Jojo there were many Oh
first we're gonna send Derek path home a
guy who I really like and don't drink
for the entire heartbreaking goodbye set
to the song don't cry for me Argentina
yes I have to say I don't know who this
woman was but that was one of the most
highbrow performances we've ever had on
a bachelor show and he was incredibly
talented and you know I love a musical
but that's not gonna be a most painful
goodbye of the season brace yourselves
as early samuel l.jackson in Jurassic
Park would say hold on to your mud hold
on to your butt's if you're in a car
let's think of this which you should not
be drive safely but yeah buckle up we'll
be back with it after the break
[Music]
and we're back in here to talk about
Luke Pell and things didn't go well Luke
I'm sorry take a moment say goodbyes
this is a set of stairs guys that's
what's happening or I'm magic Natyam
videos okay stop it Lauren okay oh yes
everybody I remember being shocked by
this breakup then and how did you feel
watching Luke and jojos goodbye now it
still seems to me this is not supposed
to be happening it is the shock in
Luke's face don't drink every time he
looks like he didn't see it coming I had
no clue but JoJo's tears didn't start
coming this is not supposed to be
happening yes why did she say bye what
do you guys think
why did Jojo sand eluc home he did say
maybe he didn't say he loved her soon
enough I had no clue I wasn't saying
that but she herself seemed so torn up
about it and this is one of the many
things that I think made Jojo a really
good lead she really felt it when she
sent someone home but we're gonna catch
up with Luke how you been great thanks
for having me on
and Luke pal does seem to be doing well
now I did not know he was I thought he
was dating somebody I must be a little
behind on my social media he seems to
not be single and oh my gosh Chris
Harrison says it come to paradise I have
a little beach down in Mexico I'm just
saying someday maybe we see it down
there
but from tantric yoga to go in a home we
are now back with Jace McNary in
hometowns and this is one of those times
when I really love the show because as
much as it is a reality television show
full of drama and conflict and sexiness
that gives us an escape sometimes it's
grounded and those really break through
personal moments for people Chase had
come from a messy divorce I grew up in a
divorced family that's really good he
talked about that openly on the show
which was admirable and beautiful and he
also seemed to grow on the show it's a
new experience for me to open up to
somebody it's a great thing to witness
the open discussion the vulnerability
the emotional advancement saying the
word love to somebody is scary Chase had
a hard time saying I love you and he
said it to a Jojo 100% in love with you
and even though that was great it did
bring one of the toughest moms
thank you for telling me that so Chase
gets to the fantasy suites and I don't
remember where they were because one
thing I have noted is that this Cliff's
Notes show is not noting where we are
going I don't remember where fantasy
suites happen but chase gives us some
clues and we're in this magical place
with monkeys fishermen saltwater and
fish on monkeys fishermen and saltwater
and fish where are they Chase is going
to say to Jojo I love you 100% in love
with you and when he does it makes her
realize that she does I don't know if
I'm in the same place as you
they're incredibly difficult emotional
heartbreaking gut
Shing unforgettable iconic dramatic
over-the-top and very real exit chase
McNary says he's been shattered and
skewered I just jumped over a hurdle
that I've never done before and now I'm
skewered I know I don't know I'm
shattered one word choices I mean what
do you want me to say
you got Excel yourself to get back up
guys I've said this before I'll say it
again it's a dark sounding statement but
if you turn to it and embrace it and
believe it it will set you free and this
is it no one is coming to save you think
about it
nobody's coming you're all you got at
the end of the day your family your
friends your lovers at the end of the
day you are all you got so you got to
pick yourself back up and keep going
bachelor historians I call upon you had
anyone been sent home right as they were
about to enter a fantasy suite before
that's what happened with chase and Jojo
and it was a Hagin I think chase I mean
I will say this for Chase he was wearing
a fabulous like white linen shirt which
I love to see a man wearing in a beachy
environment he's like a sexy pirate okay
but that sexy pirate walked away he
didn't know what to do so he cracked a
beer
[Applause]
yes I will never forget that you guys
Chase is walking away he had just been
as he said skewered and shattered
skewered now I'm shattered like a glass
kabob of a human being and he cracked a
beer got in the van and clearly told a
producer it felt like he'd been kicked
in the nuts yeah that's like pull your
pants down and kick me in the nuts
cheers to Chase for getting through
cheers to Chase for getting through so
that was a lot you guys and I think they
knew that we needed a bit of a light
moment as we were processing that blast
from the past so they now seem to have
named our weekly catch up with a random
member of bachelor nation
it's the quarantine check-in bachelor in
quarantine check-in it's like that thing
where you're you know you're doing a bit
but I really am going down the stairs
why don't I take the stairs
okay this is asking for trouble
[Music]
and that check-in is with Tyler Cameron
what's going on my friend and Matt James
yes they're besties they're in Florida
together so Matt jeans dropped in our
new bachelor
don't drink for every time they said
sensitive Florida man but the sensitive
Florida man is the Florida man so first
called dad
so double the pleasure we also get a
drop in from Matt James our new bachelor
salmon suit on GMA and then you pan down
and you see that our bachelor doesn't
have pants on yep and this time unlike
his bachelor announcement he's got pants
on who is wearing pants we'll take him
either way it's great I am so excited as
I've said you guys format season I think
what's gonna be awesome is yeah you know
what's gonna happen
we're also gonna get a little Tyler
Cameron drop in so it's just gonna be so
much fun
I actually couldn't be more excited for
the next two seasons Clare is gonna be
amazing television she has been every
time she's been on the show and I think
she's going to bring her maturity to the
show that should be dramatic and
interesting in a way we haven't had in a
while we've had really young leads the
past couple seasons and then Matt's
season will hopefully bring this next
phase of evolution and diversity for the
franchise and you guys they need it I
need the new seasons need them to air
2020 mm-hmm
but back to the past and Robbie Hayes is
in the final two hey
yes he promised Jojo a lifetime of
country clubs and coloring books country
clubs and coloring books
that's right and I forgot Jojo said
she's in love with him
I am in love with Robbie but also in the
final two were Jojo and Jordan I'm crazy
about you I'm in love with you with lots
of sexy moments kiss is up against the
wall and lots of great therapy moments
they seem to have very real discussions
like when she was talking about getting
heartbroken by Ben I want to spend the
rest of my life with you that's what Ben
said you could see that the conversation
between these two was grounded in Holly
oh we're gonna get another difficult
breakup
yes Jojo had to say oh no no no - Robbie
haze I want yours - Robbie for his
speech what he was about to propose my
futures longs for you my heart yearns
for you it was very beautiful and then
again because she's such a great leave
Oh Jo is crying emotional exits below
what do you guys think is there anything
Jojo should have done differently in
that situation let me know in the
comments below now we did not catch up
with Chase or with Robbie and I've seen
some of you asking you know how are
these decisions being made who we catch
up with when I really don't know I think
it's probably a combination of a variety
of factors I would imagine in some cases
it's like let's not catch up with that
person who the leaves no longer with
because it would feel disrespectful to
them and maybe in some cases people were
reached out to and they didn't want to
come and do a catch-up interview I don't
think it's a set protocol I think it's
varying Oh freaking out the stemless
glass and that's when I spill it's fine
silver lining we already
I'm gonna lift each other up so Robbie
is gone but Jordan is coming and Jojo is
ready I'm ready to spend the rest of my
life with Jordan yes
Jojo knows she's in love with Jordan she
is so ready she couldn't even stay on
camera the only thing that's getting me
through this moment this is the thought
of seeing Jordan she talks about how
Jordan being on his way is the only
thing getting her through the day I am
ready I am so ready and she just walks
out of the shot
and Jordan that a good speech - you're
my best friend you're my soul mate I'm
gonna keep you safe I'm gonna protect
you
this season brought us sexiness
introspective sadness and ultimately
love don't drink every time they said I
love you that I love you I love you so
much I love you
so many I love yous
oh it really was sweet to watch
everybody we were witnessing to people
who had not been able to freely say that
to each other back and forth and to just
hear it to see it how it lifted me up
[Music]
and then we're gonna jump into a zoom
with Jojo and Jordan and again they are
talking about growth
they both discussed how look the first
year off the show was difficult for them
they push through for their relationship
they've changed a lot as people and
there was a point in that first year
where it was like whoa can we even do
this we sat down together are like we
love each other but is that enough right
now it just it was a fork in the road
and we chose to stay together
grow and change I think we gotta believe
people can grow and change guys
otherwise what are we all doing here you
know if people are making efforts to be
better what more can we ask what else is
life about if not evolving save yourself
okay so that was Joelle Fletcher season
of The Bachelorette everybody what did
you think of this episode please let me
know in the comments below and next week
a real blast from the past they are
going to do a combo episode of the first
batch of lore and the first batch the
red that's gonna be wild I didn't watch
the show back then I don't think anybody
even knows where the first bachelor is
or what just do it it's a mystery
but I have been so happy to continue to
do roses and Rose a on the journey with
Jacey from the beginning and again can't
wait for this season of The Bachelorette
and the bachelor what are you guys
excited for to see on Clair and Matt's
seasons let me know if you want to find
me I am on tik-tok Twitter Instagram and
cameo and I love you guys so much thank
you for watching thank you for lifting
me up and being a silver lining of my
week okay from me and my stains
oh damn it unbelievable
good to feel emotions don't you now feel
them okay
[Music]